today we are unboxing the press kit for
the oneplus 70 just making sure there's
no hidden surprises and here it is
everything that comes in the new one
plus 70 box we have the phone he's got a
clear case SIM card ejector USBC cable
and charging brake
are you ready
and here it is the brand new one plus 70
in glacier blue the screen is a 90 Hertz
AMOLED a six point five five inch full
HD display with a 20 by 9 aspect ratio
it's 27 percent brighter than the 7
Perot it's a thousand nits for better
viewing and direct and bright sunlight
you may also notice a very small
difference here in the water drop knotch
@ 31.4 6 percent smaller as her
processor with a qualcomm snapdragon 855
plus which gives it 15% faster graphics
rendering the battery capacity is 38
million as 8 gigs of RAM and 128 gig
storage it's also got the in screen
fingerprint reader much like the
previous version but it has an upgraded
security algorithm so this means it'll
be faster and more secure when unlocking
when oneplus announced their work charge
30 we thought that was pretty fast but
now they have a work charge 30 T which
will charge your phone 23 percent faster
than the previous version you can now
charge your battery up to 70% in just a
half an hour in 60 minutes for a full
charge I'm actually super into this
camera design I don't know why like I
feel like just having it placed in the
middle everything feels very symmetric
so with these three lenses you're gonna
have a telephoto a wide and an ultra
wide
v telephoto lens is 12 megapixels and
you'll get 2x zoom the regular camera is
actually 48 megapixels which is pretty
incredible one of the things that I'm
super excited to try out though is it
has a new macro mode which is built into
the hardware so this isn't something
that is just software based it's kind of
rendering it to make it look like it's
macro it's actually getting macro shots
so you can get all two and a half
centimeters from your object which is
pretty awesome to think that you're
gonna be able to get that close and get
some really detailed shots just on a
phone so you can also use two different
views for portrait mode so you'll have
wide and close-up which is great because
I feel like sometimes portrait mode
feels like you are only able to take
just portraits so being able to move
back and get a little bit wider view but
still get that really great depth of
field look is pretty cool
video is something that is always my
favorite to test out on phones you can
shoot 4k 30 and 4k 60
so do super slow motion you can shoot
1080p at 240 frames a second you can
also shoot super slow motion so you can
get 1080p shots at 240 frames a second
but you can also get 980 and 480 but you
only be able to capture that at 720p the
front camera is 16 megapixels and you
aren't able to shoot at 4k or
front-facing but it will still shoot at
a 1080 nightscape is available on both
the main and the wide-angle lenses it
will combine information from multiple
frames to help produce better images in
low-light low-light photography on
phones obviously with the new
integration to the new iPhone 11 having
that night mode I think that's something
that a lot of phones now are gonna be
striving to do obviously the pixel was
one of the first to do it and do very
very well so to see all of the other
phones kind of following suit and trying
to catch up to what the pixel did
initially is pretty great I usually vlog
a lot and I'm always on the go using a
lot of handheld video so with this the
video it's combining optical image
stabilization along with the electronic
image stabilization and that's giving us
1 + seventies hybrid image stabilization
I did a review of the 1 + 7 Pro when
that one came out and they introduced
Zen mode and oneplus said that the Zen
mode went over so well in the previous
version that now you can set its end
mode up to an hour so the Zen mode is is
you can basically just lock your phone
you won't be able to access social media
or notifications you only be able to
send and receive calls and access your
camera which i think is really good
because there are some times where I
just want to like set my phone aside I
don't want to be bothered but yet I love
that I'm still able to make calls or use
my camera if I need to especially if
there's an emergency I think that's a
pretty cool feature the oneplus 70 will
be exclusively sold at t-mobile carriers
but you can also of course get it online
it'll be coming in two colors this one
which is the glacier blue which I've
already smudged of sorry and the frosted
silver it's priced at 599 which i think
is a pretty competitive price
considering how expensive some phones
are nowadays I just wanted to do a quick
unboxing and a test of this because it
was just announced and I know you guys
probably so sick of seeing iPhone
content so I'm so excited that we also
have some new Android phones to check
out and I'm always such a huge fan of
one class they do such a great job of
listening to the community and trying to
integrate things that we actually want
into their next version of their phones
while also keeping the prices down and I
think that's really difficult because
how do you make the technology better
and yet keep the price as competitive as
possible we also have a few cases to
check out this is the oneplus 70
sandstone is that case and all I had to
do was go like this these look great
I love the oneplus cases because they do
such a great job of making them look
really nice but also super thin and
light like this carbon fiber one it
feels like I'm holding nothing which
case am I gonna put on I think I'm
probably with a carbon fiber yeah it's a
really good look with those blue accents
hello so now that it's all unboxed and
setup but let's take this thing outside
and test out some photos and video
time to take some photos I cannot wait
to try this out especially with this
ultra wide mode in a little bit I will
also test it out in comparison to the
iPhones is the iPhone now has the ultra
wide mode I kind of want to see what the
difference is between both of the
cameras but first let's take our first
photo on the oneplus 70
[Music]
I just love the way that ultra-wide so
it's a quick little video test now let's
do a front-facing video and of course
this only it does 1080p so it doesn't
shoot 4k but let's try it out
here's a front-facing video test
watching the sunset here in Santa Monica
there's Tyler living in Los Angeles you
sometimes forget I need to enjoy this a
little more once you're back down when
you're shooting live focus or portrait
mode on cellphones is to try to keep
yourself contained so don't have your
arms up crazy and a lot of spaces like
this in your hands or your fingers the
closer you can keep yourself together
the less difficulty these cameras have
we're trying to figure out what it
should focus on one of things I'm
excited to test out its portrait Road
because this will do portrait mode on
both the telephoto and the ultra wide
which is cool because I can give you two
different perspectives so Tyler can you
take some portrait mood photos for me
okay all right
[Music]
now let's I found the wide angle of the
iPhone versus the 1 plus T and obviously
we are comparing two completely
differently priced phones so it's not
entirely a fair comparison but I want to
see what these look like
huh actually look oneplus looks like it
did a pretty good job
[Music]
[Applause]
flips us out the back remotes there's a
little macro button right here so this
takes you into super macro those let's
place the subject to 2.5 centimeters to
eight centimeters away in macro mode
let's try to get thing is little flower
we need to help low speaking that these
aren't flowers they look like some sort
of weed
this is so crazy oh my goodness look I
keep getting even closer
this looks like somebody would be under
a microscope in a lab my gosh it's a
wild
whoa
oh god did you see that and I don't even
know where it is it was so small
I think we got some pretty cool macro
shots so there's a super stable option
for video English there is a super
stable option for life okay Tyler you're
up
[Music]
[Applause]
ones I just took a nightscape just to
see if it would pull out some of the
shadows and it actually kind of did it
I'm just kind of cool
[Music]
look at that how pretty
you guys I've been waiting all day for
the Sun go down to get a nice deep shot
and then I forgot so I had to just run
outside real quick
a little a back alley and get a shot so
let's take this my cheap shot
so here's what the iPhone looks like
compared to the oneplus I'm surprised
they both actually looked pretty good
although much like most other
comparisons to the iPhone the iPhone
does have a more realistic look but I'm
pretty surprised how good the oneplus
actually does look I'm back from testing
out b1 plus 70 and I just want to look
at some of the images that I took
because it's really hard to tell when
you're looking on an actual phone screen
because everything tends to look
different one thing I will say though is
that 90 Hertz refresh rate on that
screen it looks really smooth even when
you're taking photos like everything
just looks so seamless I love it one
thing that I did notice is there is some
inconsistency in the color between the
three cameras so it looks like the
telephoto even in a couple of these they
look to be a little bit warm the Sun was
super bright but I feel like it still
should have been able to compensate for
that but even looking at it now here
like the photos actually look pretty
good you can tell the color difference
when you switch between the wide-angle
to telephoto it's at a pretty good job
with the portrait mode I really love
this wide angle like that looks cool
this photo is so funny because it
actually looks like I was photoshopped
and placed on to a massive picnic table
because I look like I've been shrunk
down and this is so weird like this
photo is messing with my mind like just
a picnic table and the way that the
background is ever blurred I look like
I've been plopped out of Polly Pocket
into the real world my biggest complaint
on previous one-plus phones is the audio
it always seemed like the microphone was
a very tinny sound and living in Los
Angeles II sometimes forget
the sounds way better so I guess this
was just my first look at the oneplus 17
no this is not it this is it this is the
7 Pro I had this out for the unboxing
and I never actually showed you guys
because I wanted to show you oh my gosh
it's so smudgy I'm gonna show you is the
camera differences between the previous
version and also sort of the color
difference so there is a little bit of
color variation because on the pro it
has more of a gradient type color so I
feel like it was a little darker at the
top so a little more of an ombre look
whereas this time it's more of a
consistent overall and a little bit
lighter of a blue but either way this
was my first look at this I cannot wait
to try it out a little bit more I am
kind of a fan of this camera arrangement
I was talking to Tyler and he said he
wasn't I'm just gonna throw you under
the bus there Tyler but now I'm not
gonna do that anymore so I'm kind of a
fan of this camera arrangement I feel
like it's a little bit different but
what I like most about it is how it
looks when I have this in a case but for
now I think I'm just gonna let it be
free no case and just let it live it's
best life another thing I noticed in my
short time with this so far is the in
screen fingerprint reader is way faster
like it just feels like it's just snappy
another difference between the 70 and
the 7 Pro is obviously the pop-up camera
which was something that I thought was
so cool that they decided to implement
in here but this is a lower-cost phone
so you are going to be losing a few of
the features in the pro version so
that's it that's the first look at the
new one plus 70 I look forward to seeing
what you guys think I know that you guys
are such big oneplus fans and I mean
honestly I am too I love the look of
their phones I'd love to hear from you
guys what do you think it is phone so
far do you have one are you gonna get
one and what phone do you guys have I'll
be reading all of those comments below
so I will see you guys
that's video so
[Music]